[Music]
[Applause]
lots of poi tricks are deceptively
difficult to learn but what if I told
you there are also POI tricks that are
deceptively easy to learn Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of boy spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today I want to
dive into five POI tricks that I
personally think are a lot easier than
they appear to be but before we dive in
I just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business friend of the
channel Becca beckonen thank you so much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission okay so first up we do just have
to state that all POI tricks take some
amount of effort on the part of the
performer to get down every single
portrait takes some degree of practice
getting down in muscle memory the basic
pieces of how to perform that specific
move but there are some tricks that I
think are deceptive in how difficult
they look as opposed to how easy they
actually are to learn now caveats here
are that easy and hard are really
relative Concepts and what's easy for
one person might be incredibly difficult
for another person but all that said I
have found five specific POI tricks that
I think when given to people in the
proper fashion that allows them to come
at them in a way that really breaks down
all the individual components to smaller
building blocks and then building up
from there well these five tricks really
are pretty awesome in terms of having a
more gentle learning curve than you
might think and that is not to
invalidate your experience if you've had
difficulties learning one or more of
these tricks but I do hope that this
opens up some doors for people in terms
of things that they might try that they
might otherwise not so with all that
said here are my picks for five really
cool POI tricks that I think are way
easier to learn than you might think
number one pendulums
okay so this one's a little bit of a
gimme just because a lot of people kind
of do pendulums unintentionally when
they're first picking up a set of poi
but stick with me because there is an
important lesson be learned here
pendulums and especially the big full
ARM version known as extendulums are a
great way to begin learning how to apply
different amounts of momentum to the POI
as you're moving them around pendulums
are a great stepping stone not only to
learning how much energy you need to put
into the POI to keep it spinning but
also to getting to a place in spinning
that I personally think is a great goal
to attain which is thinking of the POI
as being an extension of your arm and
therefore your body I think they're also
a great tool for beginning to learn how
to do transitions with POI because zero
points that is the most common tool that
we use for changing POI timing and
direction are built right into them if
you pay close attention to either end of
an extendulum you'll note that there's a
place where the momentum of the POI just
stops entirely this is a great
opportunity to switch back and forth
between say together same and split time
opposites or split Time same direction
and together opposites both of which are
great practice for when you learn how to
do this eventually with flowers and if
all these terms seem like Greek to you
but you're not actually Greek I've got
you covered I've got a beginner POI
course that I will link to down in the
description as well as up in the cards
if you're watching this video on YouTube
cool so if pendulum's out of the way
next it's time to talk about
number two POI butterflies
all right so I will fully confess that
when I was first learning how to do
butterflies they were a constant source
of frustration for me and like many
people out there that possess exterior
gonads they were also a physical
challenge as I was trying to learn them
too
yikes but here's what I didn't know at
the time there's actually a cheat code
to learning how to do butterflies that
starts with just performing them with
your arms once you get comfortable doing
this you can switch to then using the
Poise extensions of your arms and then
work your way down to producing smaller
and smaller circles until you're just
producing those circles from your wrists
and hands and when you learn butterflies
this way they go surprisingly smoothly
this was a trick that I spent weeks if
not months trying to learn how to do
when I was first coming up back in the
late 2000s and now I give this to people
and they have it down within a single
lesson usually within 15 to 20 minutes
that's pretty awesome and of course this
same technique can be used to get down
thread the needles as well once again
you just start by swapping out which
hand is on top each time your arms
produce those butterflies and then again
switch to having the POI being an
extension of your arms and then work
your way down to just doing circles with
your wrists and hands voila if you'd
like to learn more on the technique of
how to do this I have a tutorial on it
that I will link to down in the
description as well as up in the cards
and yes that is going to become a theme
in this video alright so with pendulums
and butterflies out of the way now I
want to tackle something that I only
just recently learned could be made much
more simple
number three windmills
so like butterflies this was also a
trick that caused me an enormous amount
of frustration when I was first coming
up originally I was told to learn this
trick by simply performing a corkscrew
and leaning over into it and then
straightening up my body adjusting the
planes with the top of my torso and head
and the problem is is that the momentum
and orientation of the planes relative
to your body changes completely when you
make this adjustment it actually made
this move way more confusing for me but
I was rescued just a couple years ago
when a Russian POI spinner showed me an
easier way to get this down as it turns
out we can also get down windmills by
turning our upper body over to stage
left and sweeping our left hand down and
around and then bringing it to rest back
behind our left shoulder then we do the
same thing with the right hand sweeping
it down and around and bringing to rest
behind our right shoulder we turn our
upper body over to Stage right and then
let the left hand sweep back out
followed by the right we then turn our
upper body back over to stage left and
again sweep install left right turn to
Stage right sweep install left right and
if we try to do this as one smooth
continuous motion we get a windmill out
of it who knew I really wish that this
had been the method by which I'd been
taught how to do this way back in the
day because it would have saved me a lot
of unnecessary frustration seriously big
thanks to Katya stock Anova for passing
that lesson on because it wound up being
worthament you're awesome Katya okay so
for these latitude they are going to
require a little bit of prerequisite POI
knowledge but stick with me here because
I still think that they're easier to
learn than might be first apparent
starting with
number four anti-spin flowers
okay so seriously put down the
pitchforks because yes I swear there is
actually an easier way to learn
anti-spent flowers it's not the way that
I first learned how to do them but it is
out there these involve starting off
with linear isolations that is you just
stall the POI down your Center Line and
up your Center Line and sweep your hand
back and forth from side to side of your
body when this gets to feel comfortable
you just open up and have your hand go
down as the POI goes down and go up as
the POI goes up the result being a
diamond mode four petal anti-spin flower
I truly wish that I knew that this
approach to learning anti-spin flowers
existed when I first started to learn
them I really really struggle with my
anti-spins not the least of which
because I couldn't resolve the
difference between a box mode and a
diamond mode anti-spin flower and this
exercise would have been a godsend for
me anti-spin flowers have definitely had
a reputation for being challenging
especially when compared with their
inspin Brethren but I have to say using
this method I've been able to teach
people who barely knew how to spin how
to do anti-spin flowers and without
having to go through that block of
thinking oh this is a difficult trick
for me to learn it's amazing what people
can do earlier on in their flow Journeys
cool so before I share with you my final
pick for a POI trick that is far easier
than people think it is I do have a
favor to ask if you've made it this far
it probably means that you're into POI
tricks and if that's the case then guess
what I produce a lot of videos on that
topic so if you wouldn't mind giving me
a like and a subscribe on this year
video that means that you'll be the
first to see it when I upload something
new we both win thanks in advance and
without further Ado my final pick for a
POI trick that is far easier than people
think it is
number five Zan's diamond
okay now I'm really going to be ducking
people throwing rotting fruit and things
at me but stick with me here I swear
there's a good reason why it's on this
list without a doubt the most popular
Workshop that I teach is one that
involves learning how to do linear
extensions that is just moving the hand
back and forth as the POI spins around
it and gradually building up more and
more complex patterns from Box Mode four
pedal anti-spin flowers two triquetras
two starting to create things that look
like arrows and then finally arriving at
Zan's Diamond thing is using this method
I have been able to teach hundreds if
not thousands of people some of whom had
just started learning to spin POI how to
do Zan's diamond in under an hour which
is really cool right because I was
several years into my POI Journey before
I learned how to do Zan's diamond and
certainly when I started up my POI
Journey it was thought of as being
probably the single hardest trick you
could possibly do with POI which makes
me feel good to be able to break it down
for people in a way that makes it more
accessible if I can teach people how to
do this trick inside of an hour you can
too and if you'd like to learn more
about that method that I have for
teaching Zan's Diamond I'm going to go
ahead and leave a link to a series of
videos that I did on linear extensions
down in the description as well as up in
the cards if you're watching on YouTube
and hopefully that will help you not
just get down Sans Diamond but a whole
host of other awesome POI tricks and
patterns as well so if nothing else I
hope that the big takeaway here is that
with a bunch of poi tricks you know
sometimes their bark is worse than their
bite play around with a trick before it
becomes something that becomes either
too big or too intimidating you'd be
surprised what you'll find sometimes
what poetrics wound up surprising you
either for being really challenging or
being less challenging than you were
expecting leave me a comment and let me
know
[Music]
thank you
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these awesome
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
helped to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your very generous
support and if you're out there watching
are not currently a supporter but you'd
like to become one you can do that by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world and help
people connect with their bodies and
their brains so go check that out please
and thank you and if you'd like to check
out some other videos I've done listing
off my top five POI tricks in various
different categories I will include a
link to a playlist of those down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you happen to be watching this video
on YouTube thank you so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
today and I will see you with a brand
new video real soon take care now
peace